alors vous rééditez donc se livrent les
deux printemps avec un texte et au début
de ce texte vous dit finalement je suis
raide une solide c'est parce qu'elle eut
des événements depuis sa publication
puis santé oms qui actualise mon livre
qui nous perd beaucoup mieux quelles
sont ces événements c'est un livre que
j'ai publié en 71 et disons que il n'a
pas eu beaucoup d'écho pour pouvoir
couper les dix ans après les événements
de tchécoslovaquie en soixante et dix
huit banques c'est l'année dernière que
j'ai écrit cette préface
j'ai eu envie de déclarer mon roman
en réfléchissant un peu sur ces belles
sur ces événements en faisant une sorte
de mise au point sur les événements de
cheval alors je dois dire que le livre
tel que je l'avais conçu il était
d'abord un ouvrage de fiction et même
vous l'avez remarqué un ouvrage assez
formelle pour ne pas dire formaliste et
les problèmes que je posais sur les
événements de prague dans ce livre il
n'était peut-être pas toujours très
apparent très évident pour le lecteur
alors la préface que je viens d'ajouter
beaucoup plus claire et en même temps je
m'explique sur le pourquoi et le comment
de ce livre c'est un livre très
important pour moi et que j'aime
beaucoup si un auteur a le droit d'aimer
ses rives
ces voix là et il évoque les événements
de 68 aussi bien mai 68 enfants rient
france les événements de tchécoslovaquie
c'est pour ça qu'ils s'appellent les
deux printemps et c'est en 68 que j'ai
adhéré au pcc j'étais compagnon de route
depuis très longtemps depuis 25 ans et
si j'ai adhéré c'est pas du tout à cause
de ce qui se passait en france à ce
moment là c'est parce que à prague avait
eu lieu une expérience qui me
paraissaient novatrices et porteuses
d'avenir
l'expérience connu sous le nom de
printemps de prague si vous dire que
quelques mois après j'ai vécu
l'intervention soviétique comme un
véritable désastre comme un drame et
j'ai eu envie d'aller à prague voir un
peu ce qui se passait car je n'arrivais
pas à croire qu'une une expérience dont
les significations me paraissait si
capital puisse être du jour au lendemain
liquidée et je suis donc allé à prague
exactement au mois d'avril 69 c'est à
dire au moment où la tchécoslovaquie
changé de mains ou l'an passé de double
check osé dernier un portrait du tchèque
voilà donc vous mais j'ai assisté encore
à un meeting dans le parc fou chic gens
parlent ou double chèques étaient
présents en personne
donc c'était le moment où la
normalisation comme mon fils fait et
j'ai pu voir directement à ce moment-là
ce qu'elle annonce est là c'est qu'elle
annonce et il suffit de lire le
témoignage de extraordinaire de milan
kundera dans le monde d'hier soir pour
voir où on en est et justement c'est la
destruction de l'identité d'un peuple et
de la vie culturelle de tout un peu que
je crois et ça se préparait déjà mais je
n'imaginais pas que ça pourrait aller si
loin
alors j'ai essayé dans les deux
printemps oui mais attendez je vous
arrête
est ce que vous racontez c'est
l'histoire d'un professeur d'histoire
donc qui est d'abord à prague puis
printemps paris puis de nouveau à prague
et vous articulé dans la conscience de
ce professeur d'histoire les événements
de prague et ceux de paris ça autrement
dit vous faites des rapprochements entre
eux entre les insurgés de paris mai 68
et les insurgés de prague à sauver ma
peau c'est par moi qui fais cerdon et
c'est l'histoire qui a fait ses armes au
champ puisque ça a eu lieu effectivement
68 alors le tome du livre c'est un
narrateur qui est un professeur qui
semble avoir beaucoup voyagé qui vit un
certain désenchantement
après les événements de mai 68 en france
qu'ils ont plus ou moins pris de vitesse
et les événements de prague qui pour lui
sont une
mise en question historique de première
importance et alors le livre raconte
avec des humains à travers un certain
nombre d'épisodes qui sont présentés si
vous voulez dans la perspective d'un
montage quelquefois d'un collage et qui
évoque un ensemble de situations où ce
narrateur se posent des problèmes qui
pour lui sont fondamentaux mais que ce
soit à paris ou à prague chaque fois il
se dit au fond qu'est ce que je fais
avec ces insurgés qu'est-ce que je les
comprends pas il est un peu interloqués
les gens disent ce type qui tient je
crois un problème de génération et c'est
un homme de plus de 40 ans qui se rend
bien compte que les insurgés nous
revenons à signaler proche de vous ce
qui freine et c'est pas moi comme je le
dis non je le dis en face à face est la
note
j'ai l'habitude de voir des étudiants
des jeunes c'est ce que je fais dans mon
métier
bien sûr l heure il a le sentiment que
ce sont les jeunes générations qui
prennent en charge un peu partout dans
le monde
c'est grande vague révolutionnaire ces
nouvelles secousses révolutionnaire et
il réfléchit justement à cela et il ya
dans le livre de nombreux dialogues
entre lui et les jeunes sur des jeunes
étudiants tchèques que des étudiants de
paris non il ya une chose qui m'avait
beaucoup frappé c'est que les étudiants
que j'avais vu l université charles à
prague me paraissait être à peu près les
mêmes que les étudiants qui étaient en
train de
dresser des barricades à paris c'était
le même ton le même langage les mêmes
problèmes et c'était tout de même
quelque chose d'extraordinairement
intéressant dans le cadre général de
cette année 68 je compatis vais demander
la parole mais de demander le rejet
ronnie gauche à göteborg prévenir qu'il
oeuvrait m'avoir voilà shit et à l'est
mais rêvait d'être yanai et anke alléger
un type à chaud qui devient que des
actes heroes cheikh à la pointe aval des
formations et réactionnelle sont remis à
me cormier est principe régime qui ne
correspond plus à la réalité
à quoi mais je dire de ces principes à
castres d'avant crise sont des membres
dans la véracité de fait très chaud
quand nous avons piqué que ce domenech
lâcha produit des horreurs dévore contre
john cook
mais justement ce n'est que 12e levée de
ces devises à niort livre des contes de
zinc j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des che
guevara il était dans la vie de che
guevara
antoine diot et cherche élégie et mermoz
les événements
mina qui l'achètent baby naïve à 6,2
fois qu'ils y font la malle aux
criminels et peut-être qu'un procès de
façon vraiment échelle naïma yahi des
mines qui peuvent changer le monde
gaucher est bien entendu que ces
révolutions de lécher je vous laisse
juge
et j'aime chez moi la circonstance mûri
cette addition m en ce qui me concerne
moi je pense des astros que l'image lieu
serré par amex avait sa gloire mondiale
connue mais à bienne a libéré à l'achat
et je dois débat la fille à talons qui
retentit et je ne vois guère fait parler
dans leur mère de conduite les bij et à
de tout à la fois kitsch et michael est
un débat qui met trop la tête à ligugé
hp guevara qui a de l'énergie intervenus
mais le charisme des objets à ces jeunes
actives voyant sa notation de la france
comme une chape à new delhi quelques
jours mais de pouvoir dans les deux
printemps à un moment donné ça fera
plaisir à jean que je montre une grande
image de teachers baudelaire ou alors je
cite à ce moment là sous la forme d'un
collage quatre ou cinq lignes de lui qui
sont tirées de ce texte assez ordinaire
qui s'appelle le socialisme est l'homme
à cuba
de 65,1 guevara dit dans ces lignes que
il se bat pour l'homme du xxième siècle
pour l'homme nouveau
or ce qui m'a frappé dans tous ses
mouvements insurrectionnels c'est qu'il
y avait effectivement de la part de la
jeunesse comme un sursaut pour essayer
de mettre en place cet homme d'avenir
bon jean louis curtis